LaRhonda never salatu was-salam ala
rasulillah sallallahu alayhe wassallam
thank you Ramadan Mubarak I have a short
message for you did you know how much is
spent two hundred over two hundred
million this is just what we know about
the numbers are probably much more two
hundred plus million is spent creating
hate promoting hatred of Muslims
American Muslims have been funded 200
million we have a shoestring was called
budget practically nothing we're raising
this awareness that we have a campaign
and we do once a year to help cover many
of the costs that go into a media
company a small one that we have that's
out there trying to relay the purpose to
people clear up the many misconceptions
so people can really get to know who
Muslims are the peace that we promote
the purpose that we live and his open
book that's for everybody the Quran get
to know Muslims through it read it pick
it up we have a 1-800 number six six to
Islam if you have any questions we'd
like to continue this work towards the
support we say if these people can be
spending over two hundred million
dollars to bash Islam to create create
havoc in the world getting people all
scared of Muslims in Islam when actually
Muslims will be the first to jump up and
to help you to defend you if you were in
a jam you probably didn't know that but
that's what our religion teaches that's
what Muhammad Ali was living he's a
great modern-day example and American
Muslim hero and all of that was
motivated by what by him being a Muslim
following Islam if they're spending this
money can bachelors from how much are
you going to spend to help share the
message of Islam to help share the
message of purpose the message of peace
contribute to the campaign we'll see you
next time every week new show
God willing and so long until that peace
be with you
Oh